which doesn't belong in why thursday
edition commences with a closer look at
the top half of this week's power
rankings there are three teams there
that we are putting into
the analysis which doesn't belong and
why the patriots the saints and the
tampa bay buccaneers chris right out of
the gates no screwing around which
doesn't belong and why i'm going to say
the saints um you know
they're the team that i didn't expect to
look this way i expected the patriots
and the buccaneers to be one in one i
expected it not to look exactly perfect
i think the patriots have looked
actually better than what i expected and
we saw tampa bay get back on schedule
and brady made some big time throws last
week in that game it wasn't perfect but
it was still it was something to build
on the saints
you know they look like they're the work
in progress that that's i think the
surprising thing and why i just don't
get it you know yeah
it was an ugly win in week one and it
was an ugly loss in week two so that
they're the team that doesn't belong to
me
i say the patriots don't belong because
of the three the patriots are so much
better than most thought they would be
yeah the saints are are clearly not
better than we thought they would be the
buccaneers at best are on track right
they lost week one and and tom brady
didn't look good the patriots have been
phenomenal even though they are one in
one and back to the saints we're doing
our joint chris sims unbuttoned pft pm
mega pix podcast later today i was
looking through the lines
the saints are a three-point favorite
over the packers
and and you know what maybe maybe
the packers are an illusion
based upon the fact that they've played
two crap teams but man i was stunned to
see that the saints are still a
three-point favorite with no fans in the
stands if there were fans there i get it
but you take the fans out and you let
aaron rodgers operate like he operated
u.s bank stadium against the vikings i
don't know that i would have made the
saints a three-point favorite but uh you
know those perceptions die hard that's
the challenge of of uh betting
there are perceptions that drive some of
these lines yes and the challenge is
finding those spots where the
perceptions are no longer out of whack
exactly this perception may be out of
whack that the saints are three points
better than the packers yeah i mean as
it looks right now there's no way i
would say that no way and i know green
bay you're right they haven't played
like you know the greatest teams in the
world but it's looked really good
you know in the minnesota game it was
dominant at times and then yeah
minnesota
you know put up some late points and
yards
uh detroit came out firing last week
but then packers kind of slammed that
down for a period of time to where it
just didn't matter and of course the
offense and rogers are just it's more
aggressive
it's more
just go after you and attack and i think
that's what's exciting about green bay i
mean green bay is is one of the pleasant
surprises in football to me they really
are to this point to where you know i
knew they're going to be good
they look a lot better than i thought
like they're in the conversation for one
of the best teams in the nfc no doubt
about that
here's the thing to remember though we
are inching toward that point in the
season where i call uh correction sunday
yeah and that's where the the early
season trends that we think are allowing
us to pontificate about how the rest of
the season will go get turned on their
heads out of the blue so maybe it's
correction sunday for the packers on nbc
on sunday night football next topic
seahawks rams cardinals which doesn't
belong and why um i'm gonna go with the
cardinals there i think so i mean the
seahawks and rams uh have played really
good football
i believe they're like legit two-and-oh
teams i don't know if i believe that in
the cardinals yet you know again and i
don't want to take credit away from them
but i think they were very fortunate in
week one to beat the 49ers i know they
made plays but man they were on the like
the borderline of being blown out early
on in that football game and then last
week they got to play a washington
football team that is
offensively challenged there's no other
way to put that so
with that i think they've played two
favorable matchups to where
you know it just worked out for them or
at least one favorable matchup another
one where the ball bounced their way and
they capitalized and made the plays and
i'm not trying to take credit away but
the ramps and seahawks to me are proven
commodities
and
really controlled both of their games in
a lot of ways throughout i know the
patriots made that late comeback but man
they were up 12 with what four minutes
left i mean uh those two teams have been
playing at a very high level
i i'm gonna go in a different direction
here i'm looking past the team i'm
looking at specific positions and let's
start with the most important position
on the field the quarterback position
i'm going to say the rams don't belong
yeah okay i know because yeah because
the seahawks and cardinals have the dual
threat dynamic quarterback that you need
to truly be an elite team in today's nfl
it's not good enough to be
the the
great passer
with limited ability to escape when the
crap hits the fan and jared goff is far
closer to the kirk cousins category than
the patrick mahomes category russell
wilson and kyler murray are in that
category of guys who can make chicken
salad
when things fall apart quickly and and
i'd want that kind of quarterback
without question i mean
how are teams that that don't have
quarterbacks in their early to mid 20s
not scouring every college throughout
the country looking for quarterbacks
that have that combination where you can
trust them to come up with something on
the fly when things fall apart instead
of just collapsing like the proverbial
jenga tower so that's why the rams don't
belong the rams don't have the
quarterback that can do it all and uh
you know jared goff and jimmy garoppolo
in competition for the third best
quarterback in the nfc west right now
yeah they are i don't think there's any
doubt about that i mean you know yeah
you said i mean russell and kyle are
special they're transcendent type
players that's not what garoppolo and
jared goff are you know jared goff and
garoppolo are good jared goff's been on
fire for the first two weeks but yes a
lot of his success is predicated or has
to at least somewhat be given to sean
mcvay
you know again there's just a number of
completions and i'm not trying to sit
here and bag on jared goff because he's
made some big time throws but man you
know there's a number of completions in
every game where you just go anybody
could do that anybody and i i know that
sounds insensitive um but but i think
that's the fact of the matter i get it
and you certainly can win with jared
goff but yes they're not he's not
capable of doing the things those other
two guys are doing that's for sure
and it's not just the rushing yards it's
the ability
when the pocket begins to collapse to
get away from the pressure extend the
play ben roethlisberger had an
incredible throw to deontay johnson
against the broncos where he rolled to
his right and as he was approaching the
line of scrimmage on the run he fired
the ball right to deontay johnson
special so it's just extending the play
when the play that's called for whatever
reason doesn't work out here because the
line collapses or there's a blitzer that
comes free
there are some guys that can that can
make it go and there are some guys that
can't and jared goff is in the can't and
caller murray and russell wilson are in
the can you're right it's it's going
that way too mike where you're talking
about like scouring the earth for those
type of quarterbacks it is i mean look
you know look at the first three
quarterbacks we saw this year they're
all capable of doing that you know
herbert burrow you know the year you
know the year before we saw similar
quarterbacks too you know so that's the
way the league's going trevor lawrence
he can run i mean hey if you can run for
50 yard touchdowns against ohio state
then you can run because ohio state the
whole secondary's in the nfl i mean the
linebackers the dns all of them so he
can run you're right the day of like the
tom brady the chris sims the phil sims
the pocket passing quarterback whatever
that is coming to an end you have to
have a special setup of a football team
to have that quarterback now because
you're right defenses have become too
multiple the athletes are too good and
coaches you can't expect them to win the
schematical battle play after play after
play after play you know there's only
two or three coaches in football that
can do that
and you know everybody else yeah you
need a quarterback that can make a play
yeah the pocket passer is becoming that
guy that we talked about earlier this
week if you have a great offensive line
a great running game great receiver
exactly defense great coaches we can
make it work right exactly right yes
yeah that day is coming and going as
we're watching it just unfold in front
of us right now with the watsons and the
mahomes and justin and herbert on the
scene now and everything like that you
can see that these guys can do things
that yep i don't have a play i never
told you to do that but holy crap that
was awesome and keep doing it
we just looked at three two and oh teams
in the nfc west how about a trio of oh
and two teams texans eagles vikings
which doesn't belong and why
[Music]
they don't belong because i look at them
the other two teams i have a little hope
for to rebound i have no hope for your
vikings to rebound i'm sorry it's just
there there's no there's no hope the
offense stinks they can't pass protect
kirk cousins is under attack
he's making mistakes that way the
defense there's too many new pieces
they're getting torched uh you know the
texans i could see them turning it
around to where they get back into the
playoff i mean we've seen it before the
eagles i mean i just feel like this is
the eagles and the nfc east who knows
you might win the nfc east and be six
and ten this year they're seven and nine
who knows but the vikings i feel very
confident after two weeks ago
sorry
it's not happening this year
i was on kgr radio last night and i was
trying to convince the folks in seattle
for a like
uh
kirk cousins and neil hunter trade for
russell wilson i wasn't getting any
interest yeah good luck i say that i say
that texans don't belong because the
texans i think are clearly the best of
the three teams they just have pissed
somebody off at the league office and
got the chiefs the ravens and now the
steelers right out of the gates the
steelers in pittsburgh right out of the
gates so i think they'll get a chance to
settle it down and show what they can do
but you know that that's why we focus so
much on the schedule release because
that early season schedule really can
shape a team's fortune and can put you
in a hole that you just never get out of
chris yeah no you're you're right and
then it's it's they're in a tough spot
here they can maybe go
you know you look at it and i i expect
them to lose at the steelers this
weekend but vikings jaguars they
certainly can win that football game and
we'll see the titans they're one of
those teams that are 2-0 right now where
i go i don't know how i feel about the
titans i mean the jaguars went up and
down the field on them last week that's
a little scary there so even though if
they do start all in three we've seen
billy oh and deshawn battle back before
and i wouldn't be shocked if they were
oh and three and all suddenly looked up
and went they're four and three or you
know they're four and four and right in
the thick of things it's kind of what
they do
let's squeeze in one more justin herbert
nick mullins jeff driscoll all backups
who will be likely starting this week
which doesn't belong and why um i i
think justin herbert there because he's
the future he's the franchise the other
two guys they know they're just kind of
holding a spot down for a little bit
especially you know jeff driscoll nick
mullins maybe he thinks there's a you
know a chance where he can you know
light the world on fire and make it
interesting but i doubt that justin
herbert has a chance to
like here it is
week three of the nfl season i have a
great game we win the football game and
hello los angeles chargers fans i'm your
quarterback for the next 14 years like
this could be the start of that run
right now
and what a handoff you know we've talked
about joe montana to steve young and
brett favre to aaron rodgers to go
phillip rivers oh and they already went
drew brees philip rivers they didn't
appreciate what they had in drew brees
which is why they got phillip rivers but
to go brees to rivers and now
to justin herbert with as good as he
looks uh very fortunate for the chargers
now let's see what they can do with it
as a franchise you know when you've got
the quarterback position taken care of
as a franchise you probably should get
to the postseason once in a while you
probably should win some playoff games
and you probably should be at least on
the fringes of the conversation for a
super bowl appearance we'll see if they
can pull that off i say nick mullins
doesn't belong because he's got much
more experience and as we discussed
earlier in the hour he's almost like a
coach he knows that offense he can be
the guy that kyle shanahan needs where
kyle is the guy with the joystick making
the madden game go and the quarterback
does everything that kyle wants so he's
in the best position to succeed
even though herbert's playing the
panthers who don't have christian
mccaffrey which should make it fairly
easy for charges to get a win but who
knows who knows that's that's why they
play the games that's why they play the
picks later today hopefully trying to
prognosticate some of these games
accurately this weekend
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports